I mean does it get any better than this
not for me in my life hello everyone
welcome to the show we are here with our
CBS mornings family Morning Show I mean
literally family blad D Nate bur GA King
Tony
to you see glad is back with a new baby
I got a new baby baby
girl thank you thank you how is it going
I thought that my heart was sort of
filled to the brim with all the love I
could give the people in my life but
every day when I peer into the crib when
I see her struggling to take a bite of
food or when I push her on the swing my
heart just grows a little bit bigger and
every day it grows bigger and bigger
and glad you already had such a big
heart it doesn't surprise me like more
men like you please everywhere all right
you guys we got to hit the headlines
because that's what we do all
right so here we go okay so People
magazine is reporting that Reese
Witherspoon says it's important that you
edit your friendships everybody sort of
over 40 kind of maybe already in tune
with this process um a a quote from her
is that her grandmother said uh people
are either radiators or drains that's
interesting um and she takes that
seriously okay I like that radi
drains it's like it's like bread goes
stale soda goes Flats friendships it's
like the lioning it's the circle of life
honey right BFF best friends forever in
the article they said they there's bffm
best friends for the moment yeah I mean
so I got a couple thoughts on this one I
mean I remember when I was a new dad
Vlad uh I went to a parenting group to
meet other dads uh and there's one guy I
thought we hit it off and I asked for
his number we were going to like you
know it's hard for men to make friends
particularly midlife and I was making an
effort and he said something to me that
I now respect but which stung in the
moment he said I'm not really looking
for new friends right
now he said he said I'm not really
looking for new friends right now and I
was like uh okay so I backed out I mean
that's a that's a friend edit from a man
over 40 who already had two additional
kids and was like look youngster with
kid number one like I'm going to hang
out another time and you respected it I
totally respect it and then the second
thing about friend editing is sometimes
the edit is not active right sometimes
it's because your life is really busy
and if actually it pains you it's like
you know on a basketball team there's
only five players who can be on the
court it doesn't mean that number six
number seven are not really great
players and sometimes with friends it
kind of does there are people you
no come
on you're saying that there's certain
friends that are on the back end of the
roster for whatever reason in that
season at that time right and you wish
that they could be a bigger part of the
playing well there's a quote from um
Brian a Chalker people come into your
life for a reason a season or a lifetime
I like that I thought you might G I do
like that I find number one I think it's
hard to make friends when you're over 40
but I've had times in my life with
people who I thought were my friends and
then they'll find out can you get this
manuscript to Oprah can I be on your
show can you look at this book can Oprah
pay my bills or I think you should know
this somebody who I thought was a friend
was charging behind my back $50,000 they
said I could make I can arrange a
meeting with Gail for you now I didn't
know she was doing that I did not know
she was doing that so I came up with the
best line when you decide that you want
to edit your friendships as opposed to I
don't want any more friends I said you
know I don't think I can be the friend
you need me to be oh that's good isn't
that good well I have made a new
friend uh in I think it's been about
three going on four years now I made a
friend um who has been a shoulder to cry
on someone to ask advice to um someone
who has championed me through positive
and difficult times and um it's Gail
King oh yeah yeah I did not know you're
going to say that I was hoping to fake
you out and like who is it it's you and
I thank you so much because you have
truly been someone that I have turned to
and leaned in and it is your story and
I'm just so grateful to be in this with
I'm
soad
[Music]